hello and welcome to the new world
review a source for everything anime and
manga and this time well i sort of mean
that because after a lot of comments
from you
wonderful people i decided to give a
certain series named jiu-jitsu kaisen
ago and the following will be my initial
impressions basically i've now read the
first
five chapters which i believe is the
first arc of the series named the
introduction arc very creative but just
as with the black clover videos if you
are enjoying this review then please do
like the video and subscribe to the
channel which will tell me rather
conclusively that you
yes you want to see more jiu-jitsu
kaizen content and i should also
probably point out that this is a
strictly manga-based review i haven't
seen the anime yet but it's quite new
and i thought that i'd just stick with
the manga because i'd be sure to run out
of episodes rather rapidly but let's
begin with the premise of the series
yuji
itadori is your average high school
student except he isn't because for
whatever reason he is gifted with
superhuman physical abilities but
instead of using those to
any degree whatsoever he prefers to
spend his time screwing around as part
of the school's occult research club and
during the course of said occult
research the occult research club
accidentally unseals a powerful curse
within a finger belonging to someone
known as the king of curses
shenanigan re-ensues and eventually yuji
eats not just one but
two cursed fingers yum yum and is then
abducted by jujitsu sorcerers and given
a choice of immediate execution or
execution after eating roughly 18 more
fingers or i guess 14 more fingers and
perhaps four
thumbs and so yuji gets pulled out of
high school and gets put into
another high school but a different more
sorcerific high school where he will
live and study until his scheduled
execution and that is the premise of
jujutsu kaisen and yeah i'm pretty down
with it in many ways jiu jitsu kaisen
initially presents itself as a very
standard sort of shona model you know
young high school boy with unique latent
abilities takes up a call to action in
order to help others however i think
that one of the greatest weapons jujutsu
kaisen possesses when combating that
standard framework is the overall
general tone of the series thus far judo
tsukaisen is
unapologetically morbid there were so
many moments in these first five
chapters where i just went
that's uh it's kind of dark but that's
the sort of thing i appreciate because
it indicates to me that the series isn't
going to be afraid to take on deep
subject matter like
say death when you think about it death
really isn't an idea that you'll see
explored all that often in a shonen
series because it can be quite
depressing and reminds even teenagers of
their ultimate fate in life which is to
no longer be living so i was quite
surprised when jiu jitsu kaisen decided
to focus on that
right out of the gate specifically with
the story involving yuji and his
grandfather who passes away over the
course of the chapter but not before
imparting some final words onto yuji
being when it's your time to go make
sure you're surrounded by others
don't end up like me and i don't know
how this plays with a much younger
audience but as someone who at this
point in life has experienced a fairly
substantial amount of family death in a
wide variety of circumstances that line
hit me pretty damn hard
and death goes on to hover like a
specter over just about everything
because what i really enjoy about this
series thus far is it isn't a question
of if yuji will die but when
his fate is sealed but temporarily
suspended i suppose and even yuji is
currently preparing for it by saying
things like
i already know how i'm gonna go out and
i really really
really do hope that the series follows
through with that five chapters is way
too early to tell anything but at this
point i think i might feel just a little
bit cheated if we got to the end of
jujutsu kaisen and yuji did not fulfill
this death prophecy that was set up and
i would much rather see him fulfill his
grandfather's words by dying with lots
of people around him it would be
extremely bittersweet but it's a unique
spin on the genre that i'd very much be
on board with the shonen protagonist not
destined to become the strongest or some
sort of king but instead the protagonist
who is simply
destined to die once again that's pretty
morbid as hell but i'm very interested
in the idea and the world further
reflects this through its main power
system of
curses i don't think i know enough about
them at this stage to draw any real
conclusion but it does seem to have this
nen-like aspect to it where curses are
just invisible to most people not
exposed to very specific circumstances
and only curses can be used to combat
other curses and i actually really love
the metaphor that was used to describe
curses being the use of poison to fend
off other poisons because it presents an
inherent danger with using your power at
all like there is no force of good or
purity in the series it's all bad very
very bad but we need to use the bad to
fight the worse which speaking of
jujitsukai sound is pretty damn well set
up because the goals of our protagonists
just so happen to align pretty much
entirely with the goal of our assumedly
major antagonist yuji wants to find and
eat all of the sukuna pieces in order to
die and then rid the world of his curse
but at the same time sukuna wants yuji
to find all of the pieces to combine and
regain his former power so we have this
really weird but fun dynamic
where the protagonist and antagonists
aren't really competing against each
other in fact they should be very much
helping one another which i think is
pretty insidiously ingenious with that
said if i had to pick a weaker aspect of
the series at this point and remember
it's only five chapters in so it's hard
to judge but i would say the uh the
characters are large beyond ug i can't
really say i connected with many
if any of them and when it comes to yuji
it's mostly through empathy for the
situation with his grandfather everyone
else is kind of difficult to pin down
but yuji seems like a
bit of everything he's got a piece of
that very composed cool guy happening
but he's also got a slice of derpy
eccentricity as well as some super
serious introspective drama he also has
a clear perky quality about him which is
demonstrated with my favorite ugly line
thus far being
my name is yuji itadori i'm into girls
like jennifer lawrence nice to meet you
just tells us everything we need to know
about him it's a perfect introduction i
think it's what we should all be doing
so he has a bit of everything going on
but i feel like we have yet to explore
any of those features in any great
amount of depth which obviously we're so
early on but as a result when i think of
yuji currently i sort of have this
picture of his blank face and no real
strong feelings towards him one way or
another but
i think i like him probably the worst
character in this regard for me would be
fushigoro i have absolutely no feelings
regarding him whatsoever because he's
just sort of
you know there at the moment he's cool
he has a nice design but i don't know a
single thing about him but with that
said for an opening arc that's not at
all necessary because i'm sure he'll
have his time to shine later
in terms of characters though the saving
grace for everything is definitely gojo
when he appeared i was like
oh finally someone in the series with an
amazing design and a clearly defined
personality he's just so expressive that
even though i know nothing about him i
feel like i know
him who he is which is a powerful
jujutsu dude bro with a great sense of
humor that he uses to cope with the
makar profession that he has somehow
found himself in in fact i think my
favorite line of the series so far came
from gojo when we saw the whole
flashback with fushiguro begging gojo to
find a way not to execute yuji and then
we jump cut to the present where gojo
just casually states yuji so let me
reiterate you are going to be executed
that was flawlessly executed black
comedy so gojo is definitely the
character with the greatest sense of
comedy thus far which is nice because it
breaks up the
morbidity happening i suppose everywhere
else and there are definitely other
comical characters like the principal or
our female student nobara but neither of
them are quite as solid as gojo plus
it's incredibly hard not to be intrigued
by someone wearing any form of masking
it makes me wonder what's hiding behind
the blindfold or if he needs to use it
as a condition for his own curse prowess
having briefly brought up nobura she was
a very
late addition to this early arc although
i do quite like her generally
combative style of the hammer and nail
it's quite unrefined
and very very brutal which only goes to
reinforce a lot of what i currently love
about jiu jitsu it's not afraid to dive
into a more grotesque aesthetic which is
especially prominent when it comes to
the cursed bass creatures
and it's also just interesting that the
entire power system of this world
is basically fueled purely by negativity
i believe the quote was pain regret
humiliation the more people dwell on bad
memories the more these places become
receptive to those feelings and it just
makes me wonder if there can ever be
anything resembling a happy ending to a
series like jujutsu kaisen because to
get rid of the world's major threats
you'd need to basically achieve a
utopian society with no negative
emotions whatsoever and that just seems
very
unlikely even for fiction which gives it
a slight flavor of berserk
a story about struggling against the
inevitability of the world itself but
speaking of other manga vibes jujutsu
kaisen hits me
right in the bleach very early bleach
that is when it was a slightly darker
story about a high school student
fighting hollows plaguing the real world
before it turned into
that whatever it turned into and that's
a really good thing because that initial
shade of darkness is what really
attracted me to bleach so i do enjoy
that jujutsu kaisen operates in that
sort of sphere as well
in terms of art something that i have
noticed in these early offerings is that
gege akutami seems to really enjoy
these very narrow panels whether it's
horizontal or vertical akutami makes
very frequent use of these narrow
rectangular shapes rather than opting
for a more rounded square style of
design which is much more common in
manga and i know that was a kind of
stupid thing to say a rounded square and
all but these narrow panels do give the
series a unique aesthetic and page
identity in addition to that akatami
makes very common use of breakout panels
like this one here where the artwork
isn't actually contained within the
shape of the panel another mangaka do
this on occasion but it's usually
only for big dramatic events like
character reveals or some sort of action
piece otherwise the large majority of
shonen authors very much play within the
boundaries of their established panels
but i really love akatami style here
because it gives you the illusion of a
satisfying and rigid panel structure but
it allows the images within those panels
themselves to truly stand out even when
we're just engaged in basic dialogue so
it's very much like the panels are
acting as a background frame to the
image rather than containing the image
if that makes sense and i know that's
probably a really tiny thing that i
didn't need anywhere near that long to
praise but it's a piece of unique
aesthetic flair yet
another piece of unique aesthetic flair
that i like about the series and one
more thing i do enjoy about the art
specifically is that akitami makes very
deliberate decisions regarding detail
for example when we're in a more casual
day-to-day situation we are given this
very flat character rod and often with
no background whatsoever just often pure
white or black negative space meanwhile
as soon as something curse related comes
up this unimaginable amount of detail
just springs into existence and it's
almost as if it's breaking the war
between manga and reality which once
again is very subtle decision but it's
quite a cool device to attention to any
given scene now as for how this arc ends
all i can say is that this is pretty
damn ballsy we basically arrive at the
end of the introduction only to be met
with a mission report from the future
which basically states that one of our
first-year students is going to die so
yuji
nobura or fushiguro once again bringing
the motif of death right back into
things it's the sort of thing that made
me really want to launch into the next
stock but the more i think about it the
more kind of skeptical i become the
boldest possible decision would probably
be to either kill nubra or fush guru but
at the same time i have to ask myself
why because they've both just been
introduced and have yet to be exported
all but then again if it's yuji then
it's kind of false drama because he'd
have to be revived somehow
or die purely on a technicality to
continue the series because as much as
he is resigned to death we have
some more digits to consume before that
can happen so i really did like the
ballsy ending i just have many doubts
that said balls will be ultimately
delivered with that said i think
jujitsukai sen is off to an incredibly
strong start i'm not wildly attached to
the characters but the whole concept and
tone has me incredibly gripped there's
only one other thing i forgot to mention
actually which is one of the principal's
lines that stated
this i can say for sure no jiu-jitsu
sorcerer dies without regret which is
just another in a long line of rather
grisly statements and ideas
all presented to us within this initial
set of chapters and i have to say i
am all on board for it but that pretty
much does it for this blind review of
the introduction arc of jiu jitsu kaisen
and what do you guys think please do
leave your thoughts in the comments
below or even join my discord server and
if you are keen to see more jujutsu
sorcery then please do check out some of
my other videos or even subscribe to the
channel for very maybe regular
jujutsukai send morbidity delivered
straight into your youtube
feed but for now this has been the new
world review and i'll see you next time